the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license
your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so I guess one quick announcement is
eyes so I guess everyone has taken a
look at the prizes if you can take a
look at the prizes and especially if
you're near the top and expect yourself
to be getting some prizes so we haven't
announced the final ordering yet because
it would also depend on like the
homework and will decide you know how
much it will mostly just be number
points that we might give a bit of
waiting to people who have like high
points per game or something so but if
you you know if you think you have a
decent chance of getting prizes it'd be
good if you look them over you know can
you research through this like Michael
McDonald guy is how much is it's
coaching where is you can do that
beforehand so that people don't take
like forever deciding which prize you
want on Friday ok so I'm gonna get so
dead so this is gonna be the last class
I'm gonna teach so next the final class
on Friday is going to be guest lectured
by Bill Chen so I wanted to go through
sort of an in-depth combinatorial hand
analysis of a cash in hand go very
in-depth on you know a very and where
you have deep stacks and there's a lot
of action and there's a lot of deduction
that should take place and then I'll
sort of finish with some general poker
stuff and answer any questioning those
might have about like the poker economy
how certain things work the history of
poker I'm happy to answer whatever
questions ok so first we'll do something
more technical and more practical to the
game so an in-depth combinatorial hand
analysis and cash teams so I'm going to
look at the following hand and the board
is visible it's good ok so this so this
is a cash game this is no longer a
tournament now and everybody has a
hundred big fines so the blinds are one
two and
200 so it's 100 big blinds the cutoff
open 36 and we have 8 7 suited on the
button and when it's this deep stacked
so in a tournament this might not be a
good situation to call because it just
puts a lot of risk on you to bust and
also you're not really that you sack but
here with a hundred big blinds we can
really realize a lot of our employments
given that we're both in position and we
have a hand that plays very well as
suited connector that can make straights
and flushes so we just send a call and
the big blind also calls okay so the
flop is 1086 with with the club and the
cutoff continuation that's 14 so one
thing I'll talk about first is you know
continuation bet sizing so I've said a
bit about this but I wanted to talk a
bit more about bat sizing and it's
really just this is really just sort of
view of what I've been talking about all
class it's the same principles when
deciding your flop in turn bat sizing so
you know you don't want about so small
that your opponent has the odds to call
with anything but you don't want that so
big that you're risking a lot of chips
when you're bluffing and also if you're
raised size commits your entire stack
anyway like if you're roughly let's say
betting 40% or more of your remaining
chips then you might as well go all-in
if it's the flop or the turn because you
probably aren't gonna fold with like
given that your hand is good enough to
put in 40 percent of your chips you
probably haven't have enough equity that
you're okay putting in 100% of your
chips yeah remember that raising their
bet gives them the option to be raised
so that's always an incentive against
raising the flop bet the sizing should
be bigger on drawing boards and smaller
and dry boards we talked about this and
you want to bet bet a bit bigger when
you're out of position so he's kind of
out of position here against us and he
bets 14 into 19 which is a reasonably
big bet but I think that's fine so with
our hand here eight seven of clubs I
think we definitely don't want to be
folding so let's talk about the
differences between raising and calling
so we decide to call and so what's the
what's the what's the analysis so we're
definitely not folding raising I think
is a bit suicidal away
we have a medium strength hand that can
play well in the position of a lot of
turns and we had a little backdoor flush
draw and our straight draw is very
legitimate when there's no flush draw
out there so we decided to just call we
we have to be a bit worried about a big
flying check disease but I think it's
it's okay it's not that big of a deal
especially when there's no flush drop so
the big blindfolds and on the term is
the queen of clubs and he bets 30 okay
so this is sort of a tougher decision
now and then the flaw I'd say so let's
let's analyze this so he bets 30 into 47
we've got 180 behind which is about four
times to five and we've got we've got a
pretty bad hand right now oh we spoke we
sound like care and we have lots of
chances to hit a straight or hit a flush
or hit like three of a kind or hit two
pairs so some tons about tons of Ripper
cards that help us and so what are the
benefits of each okay so so I think it's
fairly clear we're not going to hold
here with this much equity so what are
what are the benefits of calling what we
get to see the river for sure right if
the river is a club then it's we don't
want to like fold in situations and not
see the river when it could be a club
which is the best color for us
essentially we yes we really want to see
the river because he actually raised
then maybe they could rebase all it and
then we would have to fold so that's
that's why I'm player benefit and
another sort of benefit is we don't have
a pair to start with so you know we
don't really need you Bluff doing the
hand right so this is something I've
been talking about a lot to you you
don't really want me to if your hand you
don't need to raise to win the hand
because you already have a pair then
there's a lot more incentive to call so
what are some benefits of raising well
if you're getting me fold something like
pocket jacks if we think he might have
like pocket jacks it can definitely get
them to fold subbing better in hands and
we can like bet the river and with a
bigger pot when we hit and we can also
maybe make some bigger Bluffs
one we miss so well go through a more
detailed analysis in a bit but I think
calling I like calling in
situation I think with the draw that has
no showdown value like say I had nine
five of clubs instead of eight seven of
clubs which has a pair I think I would
raise because for two reasons one is I
like I would need to block the river
anyway if I miss the river so if I raise
now I just give myself a chance to win
the pot right now and another benefit of
raising is that I can I am not that
unhappy if he goes all-in because my
draws sort of less strong than eight
seven of clubs is okay and then yeah
maybe with a hand like East Jack of
Clubs I would raise just because we can
maybe get it and against weaker flush
draws okay so yeah so this is a sort of
a general principle that I haven't
really talked about for playing on slots
insurance is in general I mean this sort
of goes along with most of the stuff
we've talked about in this class but in
general when you have like stone-cold
nuts and when you have weaker draws you
sort of want to you want to be the one
you want to be betting and raising in a
way such that your opponent gets the
last better so I'm talking about like
you know so one person is always going
to go go all-in first right like if
you're raising each other or betting and
raising one person is going to go all-in
first and the other person basically has
to decide whether to call or fold and
play for your stack so if you have a
stone-cold nuts then you sort of want to
be the person having your opponent go
online first because obviously you have
a very easy decision you just call it
you're gonna win on the other hand if
you have like a weaker draw which is
essentially your bluff right because we
don't want to be bluffing with
absolutely nothing we want to be
bluffing basically with their weaker
draws that's it's also an easy decision
because like if let's say we have a gut
shot straight draw so we have a four
outs only we're not that sad if I Bonin
goes all-in on the flop or on another
chunk we just fold we have an easy
decision whereas um if we have a more
vulnerable good and letting up top here
with a medium kicker then you know then
it's sort of a tough decision right so
we don't really wanna we don't really
want to be letting like it
corner goes all and we have a tough
decision we're not sure what to do and
say with like if we have a stronger
drought like say we have a flush draw
and we have nine outs and then our woman
goes all-in on the flop and we had like
one point six to one odds they call or
something it's it's a difficult decision
and so it with these hands you
definitely want to you generally want to
bet in race in a way that allows you to
get the last bet it because with the
stronger draw you're not you know your
opponent gets to make a decision but
even if they have the nuts you still
have nine outs and with the more
vulnerable good hand I mean if your
problem has the nuts I guess you're kind
of dead but you're sort of protecting
the times you go all in with your
stronger does so following that
principle I decided to just call here
because if I raise then I sort of have
to make a decision when he goes all-in
whether to call with my medium strength
hand and pretty good draw okay so we
call and rivers an ace of spades so we
completely missed and our moment checks
to us so so we just have to bluff the
river for 70 and this is sort of the
main decision I want to analyze and it's
gonna be quite a complicated decision so
so okay let's do some quick analysis so
yes we do have some chances of winning
with our pair of eights so maybe you
could make a case that there's no need
to bluff because we do have a pair but
there's a lot of reasons to bluff so one
is there's a lot of higher cards on the
board now the pair of eights it looked
pretty good on the flop but now it's a
lot worse after a queen turn and an ace
River so you know we could get in the
fold a queen
he could have a queen and he could very
willingly be able to fold also the pot
is big like they bet the flop and the
term and we called the fog and the term
so sort of both ranges are just very
strong because so much money has already
gone in so a pair of eights is not so
good you know what's it like if you knew
that he had two random cards sure a pair
of eights will win the decent percent of
the time but when you know you're up
against a hand that was willing to bet
to flop and bet the turn it's less
likely the pair of eights is good and
then the East is always a scary card and
another advantage of bluffing is this is
why position is so pretty especial
when it's deep stacked in the cash game
we're in position and we know that he
checked the river so you know maybe he's
trapping with like King Jack but it's
more likely than not that it's a sign of
weakness that he checked the river so we
could try to block them off his hand
okay so what about riverbed sizes so so
it's the one thing as whether to block
to is if you Bluff how much do you bet
so I decided about 70 into 107 and so
what are the things to consider when
you're deciding your remember best
sizing so one is there's no more cards
to come on the river so in some sense
there's less of a worry of betting
really really small because there's no
such thing as like letting your opponent
see a draw but it still has a
disadvantage like if your opponent
checks to you and you bet small it still
does give them the option to check race
so that is one thing you worry about if
you're trying to bet really strong and
another thing is you should bet big if
your range is polarized so I polarize I
mean you either have the stone cold
that's or you have a bluff because your
opponent bailiff basically if you bet
small and your range is polarized your
opponent can just call with a very wide
range of hands because there aren't very
good by betting big you give your
opponent worse odds to call and since
you have a stone cold Bluff some percent
of the time you don't want your opponent
you have the odds to call it like third
pair okay so okay so it doesn't matter
what they did because our decision is
betting 70 okay so now what I was sort
of want to do is a lot happened this
hand right we know they raise the
preflop bat flop bat-turn checked River
right so in some sense we have a ton of
information so in the tournament set you
played maybe a hand like this doesn't
show up that often because often it's
just all in preflop and you can't really
deduce that much about your opponent's
hand you know is this like he has the
top it's 30% of hands or something but
here we can actually do a lot of
deduction so let's replay the hand from
our opponents perspective and sort of
exploitative ly put them on a range so
let's like go with put ourselves in our
opponents shoes consider all the actions
they did consider so I'm going to use
exploitative
analysis here so you know there are some
flaws with this right we are sort of
arrogantly assuming more one step ahead
of our opponent we can build a
mathematical model for our opponent but
still this is a useful exercise even
though yes there are flaws you know
maybe he's one step ahead of us
maybe there's flaws in our probabilistic
model but let's just assume for the sake
of the exercise that we can do this
prism okay so first of all preflop
what's our opponents range let's say
roughly he's opening from the cutoff
let's say he's opening about 30% of
hands I think that's about reasonable
for like an average player and I think
it's consistent with the guidelines I
gave in the first lecture so so this
includes any pair any suited ace any to
Broadway cards which are cards ten and
higher it includes stupid hands of
status five three stupid this is maybe
like one difference between cash games
and tournaments it where is five three
suit is a pretty bad hand in tournaments
when it's so short but when it's a
hundred big blinds date a hand like five
three two bid is a lot better than a
hand like ten eight off suit so so yeah
so we can play two five three suited but
not like $90
is or like King seven off which are just
terrible hands when it's 100 big blinds
deep so okay so what's our opponents
range here so they decided to
continuation the bet the continuation
bet into the flop against two players
after the big blind check so okay what
can we put them on so okay so right so
this is a complicated analysis and you
can't really do this in during the game
itself but it's very useful to do it
after the hand so let's remember the
factors of why a player would
continuation bet and then consider why
he thing to do a should bet okay you're
still right so this is also sort of a
new class it's the last bus right so
what what are the incentives for
continuation betting well your hand is
good enough that it beats most of their
calling hands right so you're betting
for value or your showdown value is poor
but you have some equity you have some
back to equity you have some over cards
of draws and you're essentially bluffing
another incentive is you're out of
position like he is and it's not like
you can see a free chunk card by
checking because I can still bad
so you know so you want to bet few
opponents you want to that in symptoms
against continuation betting one is your
hand is so dominant that you need to
give them a term card to hope that he
improves so this is like the trump this
slope like you have a decent showdown
value but not amazing showdown value so
like middle pair you don't want to
continuation bet if you have like zero
equity on a reasonably draw board like
this one and there's too many people for
your fooled out or like your position
and you can see a free turn by checking
so there's a lot of things but so let's
look at the situation again keeping some
of those factors in mind key
continuation bet and do 1086 rainbow
which means three different suits
okay so let's roughly put him on okay so
actually before I show this slide
what's it let me think what the best is
weighted okay I'm gonna use the annotate
future and will chart sort of try to
write on here what hands we think you
can have so this is this is gonna take a
while but I plan on spending the next 20
25 minutes discussing the same okay so
does someone want to say a hand that you
think is in his range at this point
pretend we don't know what he's gonna do
on the term and you just at this point
in the hand can someone tell me a hand
you think is in this range oh yeah okay
yeah he's Jack okay yeah I think that's
reasonable it's actually I think a bit
weak but let's say like ace Jack ace
Jack suited with the back or a flush
draw or okay already done these Jack for
now okay so someone want to tell me
another yeah no limit up there maybe not
so good I just hate them okay East 10
Jack 10 ten nine okay someone want to
tell me another type of hand maybe yeah
okay pocket jacks yeah so that's a clear
value hand yeah okay someone want to
tell me sort of another type of hand
what about Queen Jack Queen Jack that's
a good yeah that's a good one so Queen
Jack I think is like one of the best
drawers oh maybe not the best drawer
what what is the
stop what'd you say queen Jack of Clubs
Queen Jack of Clubs yeah but Queen Jack
of Clubs only it's not the best straight
draw right yeah what's yeah jack now
Jack nine or twenty nine so okay so I
I'd roughly I wrote some cancer okay
Jack nine or Queen nine or like five
seven okay is it possible pocket sixes
yeah yeah yeah okay that's good yeah so
I'll write that down so pocket six is
good here's a question what do you guys
want to put in mine if he has like a
really really good hand like what do you
do so this is open-ended I didn't come
with the plain answer you guys want to
assume that he checks with pocket tens
and like nine seven basically the
absolute best hands on this board to
trap us or to do on I assume that he
bets okay yeah that's a reasonable
assumption I think it can go either way
with pot with nine seven and like pocket
tens depending on our opponent pocket
sixes I think is a clear bet whereas
pocket tens is not because pocket tens
you're taking away so many of the top
their hands from your opponents where is
pocket sixes just get so much value when
you bet okay so so roughly speaking you
know I sort of categorized all the hands
he could have ended five categories so
the first the top is hands that are so
good that he checks to trap or check
raise the second category is like the
hands that are good but not that good
heat value bets then it's like medium
strength hands that he checks should
check call hands that so this doesn't
agree with exactly what we wrote but
that's okay but this is just roughly and
then the next category is hands that
heat gloves and then the last category
is hands that he just check folds
because they have middle one would be
like pocket threes where he would just
give up the hand
so we basically crossed off the these
three categories right because with
these three categories he would check
whereas the talk when he's checking me
trap the second one he's checking evil
quarter showdown and the last one he's
checking to give up and then the two
types of hinges betting are essentially
value bets and like drawers or gloves
okay so now let's consider the situation
on the phone okay so so once again okay
so let's get to let's consider his
incentives first for betting again on
the turn sorry this is a bit hard to
read maybe I should maybe I should do do
it on notepad so that it's the annotate
isn't annoying sorry just give me a sec
okay so what are the incentives for
betting again on the turn so one is you
better do painful value on the flop and
your hand is still good on the trip
right so you're betting for more value
to is you bluffed a speculative hand on
the flop and now you either hit the turn
like the queen helped do so it's like if
you have jack nine or you improve your
drum or like an over card to the board
came which was the case and maybe you
thought bluffing the term could be so
okay so so he bet the turns so okay so
let's maybe put the hands we think he
could have into poker soap so yeah I
think that's the easiest what you do it
okay so let's do this okay so I'll give
some roughly speaking can everyone see
this this is easy enough to see right
okay so okay so let's do this this is
good this is it so bear with me yeah
this is a meticulous exercise but um
okay so let's say preflop thirty percent
okay this is about reasonable actually
let me give them a few more pairs I'll
take away a six off let's say he goes
suited suited connectors down to five
more suited suited one gaffers down
these five three suited suited to
captors so to sue so suited to gaffers
means like super cards that are two
three apart essentially down you're like
eat five suited something like this
something like this is probably probably
another that's eighty plus ten succeeded
okay
something like this maybe take away like
some of the worst off suit pants okay
so something like this a ticket so on
the flop what happened on the flop we
okay so let's eliminate hands what can
we eliminate right so this is his entire
range of possibilities people oh it's on
the flop we're gonna eliminate pocket
twos threes fours fives because he just
gives up pocket sevens and nines we're
gonna eliminate because we're gonna
assume he checks five three I think it's
bad enough we can assume he gives up
let me just display the flop so that let
me just just display the flop so that we
can see okay right so okay so what else
okay so let's go through let's go
through everything I'll do this a bit
fast but so let's say so okay let's say
all the middle pairs he's going to check
so I'm gonna remove most of the hands
with an 8 in them yeah so ace a king a
queen 8 Jack okay so Teddy he's gonna do
that just because you have an 8 pretty
much yeah so we will take that into
account but but he can still happening
right so we still yeah yeah here it is
off cycling we will we will take it into
account at the very end so he's fine
let's assume let's assume a lot of these
off suit aces he gives up because
because even with over cards but with no
backdoor flush draw on a dry board I
think is kind of scary in bed okay so
let's say something like this on the
flop eight five looking like that eight
seven I think he'll check so 1978 we're
gonna serve me best let's assume you
checks pocket tens let's assume we also
check some of the weaker some of the
weaker some of the weaker tens like Jack
10 let's let's suppose each X okay so
this is about maybe ten nine he checks
as well
10 7 he checks I guess like okay 98 98
he checks okay am I missing anything to
someone see something that you disagree
with king queen off King jack off I
think those are too weak to bet and do
this board Queen nine
King nine suited a sign down here okay I
think I think this is this is roughly
it'll get easier on the turn basically
okay so so let's say this is what he's
gonna have on the flop
actually some of these weaker aces
probably should be eliminated okay let's
eliminate everything down to each five
envelope a seven and a Stein will keep
in because he has a straight draw okay
let's do this okay so on the term he
bets again right so okay someone want us
suggest a hand that maybe we should
eliminate because he bet the turn yeah
anyway to them say yes okay good yeah I
think that's a very good answer yeah so
let's get rid of ace ten King ten
because those are no longer good hints
or they're no longer I think hands that
you want to really continue betting for
value right Queen ten is good because
it's have to care okay is there another
hand that sort of other similar category
so I guess pocket shots is of a similar
category right it's not as good as it
once was
okay so what are some other hands maybe
you don't want to bluff with you don't
want to bet with anymore are there any
hands I think maybe he would just give
up because the six five yeah I think
that's reasonable
I think the hands like I think the hands
like most of these we can assume he's
going to give up on the Queen like five
four especially you know on the flop so
on the flop
she didn't even have a great hand it was
just trying to a seven but now it's sort
of worse so yeah let's go to five four
Arthur do you think they would continue
betting like nine six or seven six yeah
even seven five is a pretty bad is a lot
worse after the Queen because seventy
five was like drawing to a nine but now
when the Queen comes the nine is not a
good card because we still lose to a
jack so maybe we can get rid of that one
do you think they definitely continue
betting with East King East Queen East
Jack and all those yeah if you
yeah yeah yeah so he's queen I think is
good yeah yeah I think this is enough
good um h9 you know some of these hands
I think they would probably stop
laughing look like I think Jack seven
suited is pretty
maybe some of the sixes also I think
it's hard to even like ace seven suited
I think it's hard to continue bluffing
because as you see there's already
enough hands with drawers right like
there's there already a lot of Bluffs
here like King Jack Ace King I guess
like Queen nine nine six some of these
so now maybe he'll off with these but
okay let's get rid of these okay so okay
so we've sort of cut down his range a
bit alright so now it's a river
situation and he checks so what does
this mean well it seems improbable that
our opponent would be trying to trap us
with this check because he's already
been showing plenty of aggression so
it's hard for him to like pretend he
suddenly has a bad hand by checking and
what the part is so big he could get a
large percent of our remaining stack
into the pot just by betting instead of
check raising so it seems like it's less
likely he's checking as a trap and also
the ace is sort of a better card for his
range than ours because he's the one
who's defending so you know having
drawers having over cards like aces and
for us were much less like likely than
him to haba nice so if it's a better
putter in his range he should be betting
both for value and with his Bluffs
so that being said so let's suppose we
we assume it's sort of unlikely he has a
really really good hand but he could
still easily have a hand that beats ours
and calls our potential Bluff so okay so
now let's go back to poker so and and
eliminate some more hands okay so what
are some hands we can eliminate after he
checks the river hey should see I think
that's a good I think ace is pretty
clearly he'll bet again on the river
what's another hint yeah King Jack I
think it's okay so let's eliminate all
the good hands that would think he's
gonna continuation bet it right I think
any straight
it's reasonable to assume they're just
gonna keep getting like 97 even though
it's nowhere near the monster it was on
the flop
you know it still only loses the
Jackpine in King Jack so let's get rid
of that one certainly like a squeeze
yeah so okay so let's let's go so let's
suppose yeah I think any most strong two
pairs I think definitely he'll like a
kilt eBay so let's do that so let's get
rid of ace Queen let's get rid of Queen
Queen let's get rid of Queen ten I think
Queen 10 is good enough a state let's
get rid of that one I think yeah that's
good enough pocket eights pocket 6s I
think is good enough okay good so okay
so we got some hands here basically all
the good hands we removed right all the
really good hands that he bets again
what do you guys think about ten eight I
guess it doesn't matter too much but let
us say let's so let's assume he checks
ten eight because by this river 10 E is
no longer the power house it was oh I
gotta get rid of jacket on okay
what are some other hands you think we
can eliminate so there's actually
another category of hands we could
potentially eliminate here yeah uh-huh
well an ace isn't that good of a hand I
don't think it's I mean right so this is
one problem with this analysis is you
know that it is very subject to debate
what we think about our opponent but for
the sake of this exercise I'd say I mean
I also I think in practice I think it's
not clear that you should value bet in a
suitor because there's just a lot of
stuff that beats you a lot of straights
a lot of two pairs I think it even if
you have East King you shouldn't really
be confident enough in your hand you bet
like maybe ace king is marginal but
definitely not like h7 yeah yeah exactly
yeah so that's what I wanted to hear
yeah so so we can also eliminate some of
his really weak ace right this is
crucial this is an easy thing to miss we
can probably assume he's not gonna have
King seven because like the ACE is a
reasonable card be bluff
you know it's it's not
it's not like the use of clubs which
would be a better card for him to bluff
but if he's got nothing like if he just
completely missed probably I mean let's
assume you know these guys are pretty
good players he's probably gonna block
so let's assume he can't have King let's
assume he at least has a hitter he has
some showdown values they use it he had
zero showed me he would Bluff
so let's get rid of King seven let's get
rid of King nine six five six four you
know I think definitely
he should be bluffing but maybe some
players will see a pair of sixes and say
oh I have enough showdown value and so
let's get rid of one of them but not the
other maybe that's reasonable so let's
hear it - lets get rid of six four and
seven six but keep in six five and
ninety six okay so we leave ourselves
with these okay so this seem this seems
about reasonable I think maybe like
maybe we can eliminate yeah let's let's
eliminate like a seven I think each
seven is maybe I think we should have
eliminated it on the turn maybe like a
seven of clubs we can all know eight
seven of clubs you can't have but it
because we have the seven of clubs I
think any other a seven other than the a
seven of clubs is kind of bad you bet on
the turn because it's the seven isn't
really that good of a card you isn't
that good of a draw so let's get rid of
these seven okay so so let's suppose
it's this okay so okay so now okay so
roughly speaking we conclude his range
on the river is something like this so
let's assume that he's gonna call with
talk here or better
once again this is you know a pretty
strong assumption but let's suppose this
is the way we think he's gonna play
using the quality as an ace or better
and folded us so we're risking
70 to win a hundred and if it's illicit
let's do so yeah so let's do an exact
calculation now how many combinations of
these hands okay so okay so let's do all
this on notepad
okay okay let me hold up the board okay
so okay hopefully people can see this
okay so now okay so one that's a
combinatorial hand analysis I mean we're
going to basically count the
combinations and like you pointed out
this is oh crap did I accidentally get
rid of that okay let me quickly put it
back so okay we had Kings left Ace King
ace Jack it's nine King Queen Queen Jack
Queen Jack Queen I'm cleaning nine what
else 10 8 10 6 8 6 we had some sixes
right 7 6 6 5 and is there something
else I'm missing does anyone does anyone
remember this remember us or something
I'm forgetting to check off I'm not p9
off I guess I think this is about right
maybe I'm missing like one or two things
no one sees anything I think this is
approximately over hydrate okay yeah
yeah hopefully I didn't miss enough that
it drastically change it shouldn't but
ok so let's count it at combinations
because you can look at this square on
the poker stove and yeah let me clear
this annotation sorry I should have done
that a while ago okay so um you can sort
of see the yellow hands on this square
and sort of roughly see how many hands
of each type right so there's there's
essentially three types of hands he
could have right there's uh there's
hands that call there's hands that beat
us and call those hands that beat us and
fold and there's hands that we beat and
fold but the thing is if you just look
at these yellow squares it won't give
you the right problem
because we have certain cards in our
hand and also because of the specific
ways suited combinations work there's
different combinations of each hand so a
so let's go through this so how many
combinations of Ace King are there Ace
King suited are there that so we a
certainly add a back to a flush start on
the flop but so how many combinations of
Ace King suited are possible the don't
worry about that I have a bus drop part
it doesn't matter for this example so
how many combinations of East King
suited well three Mississippi gonna have
to be stupid and it can't be space
because the ace of spades is on the
board so yeah so so it's three call
three combinations okay ace Jack suited
three a bigoted ace nine suited three
okay good I pocket kings right it's a
pocket kings are six because there's no
kings we don't see any kings and there's
no such thing as suited miss so so yeah
so one thing you realize in this osa
pocket kings were assuming he's gonna
fold one thing I realized in this
exercise is you got to put a lot of
weight on the off suit hands instead of
the student hands because the student
the off suit hands
combinatorially having way more
possibilities essentially three times as
many possibilities I'm in the suited
hands so like this Queen Jack offsuit
hand here it has a huge weight in our
calculation that's by far it is most
likely hand because it's the only off
suit hand we're putting them on yeah
it's the only opportunity is it really
only the off suit and he could have I
guess according to our law analysis
we're assuming the only off suit and you
could have this queen jack off so how
many combinations of Queen Jack Roth are
there okay so this is a queen Jack and
toes Queen Jack and Queen Jack suited
plus off suit is twelve because we see a
queen so there's four jacks three Queens
three times four is twelve it could be
suited or not suited so okay that's
counselor bill to those what about king
queen suited
so it's three as well but I'm gonna put
it as two because I'm going to assume
assume if he had kooky
of Spades which has no flush draw like
no running runner runner flush sir on
the flop I'm gonna assume that he would
have told the King Queen of Spades on
the flop so so I'm gonna give it to okay
so which one's haven't we done queen
nine suited how many combinations three
degrees okay
ten eight suited these get fun so the
reason why ten eight is suited is
because we're assuming he doesn't raise
tehnique off suit preflop from that
position so that's why tending has to be
seated so how many combinations of ten
eight Susan - okay
how many combinations of ten six suited
- how many combinations at 8-6 suited
what yes okay okay so I didn't know I
missed categorized this one so clean
nine is in this category that he's
folding these are all the hands that
Paul Karloff and beat us and okay so the
last category is the hands that we can
actually put get me to check it down so
it's very small right it says seven six
suited and six five suited okay so seven
six student how many combinations - six
five three two - three
okay did I miss anything I think this is
it right okay so we basically we have to
tally it up so here there's 14 here
there's 23 and here there's five okay
and then essentially okay so now that
we're done this calculation we need to
we need to basically run the numbers
with these calculations
so essentially roughly speaking they're
gonna fold they're gonna fold more than
half the time so they're gonna pull more
than half the time and so the numbers I
think this will actually come out close
because with a way we did this specific
calculation there we I think we gave
them a lot of combinations of hands that
we can actually check and beat but I
think this is still this will still
definitely call for a bluff
but it is close as you if you've done
the homework the homework sort of
addresses this right it's not just what
probability is evolving it's the
probability that's sorry it's not just a
probability he's calling her Bluff it's
the probability he's calling out luck
versus the probability we win the hand
by checking and the probability we win
the hand by checking is roughly 5 out of
42 so which is pretty small and he's
full of more than half the time so if
you run the numbers you'll see that
bluffing is overwhelmingly profitable
and I think this this is this is it's
this is a good example of why this
combinatorial analysis is good it's
because if you look at Poulter still
when you look at this you might actually
think you know bluffing is bad because
you look at most of the hands you know
ace king is jack 8 9 10 8 10 6 8 6 it's
hands that it's hands that call us and
beat us but when you do this
combinatorial analysis you'll realize
there's way more combinations of Queen
Jack than there are eight six so looking
at this itself isn't quite enough
because this doesn't wait the
probabilities of each one correctly so
yeah so this is a good exercise to do I
think even though you know we made a lot
of assumptions in our model but it's a
very good exercise to do to after after
the fact to sort of just analyze what
are the different all the different
possibilities okay so I'm gonna take a
quick break here and then for the last
half of the class I'm gonna I'm just
gonna talk about some general poker
topic so no math no poker hands but just
in general acceptable holders and ending
remarks since this is the last time I'm
teaching since Bill Chevy's coming
outside if you want to doing the way
think about any questions you might want
to ask me about poker in general or
specific hands yeah so I'll take you
like a two-minute 4-h make sure your
hand in the homework
all right so I'm gonna wrap up with some
general thoughts about poker and poker
in general so one question that I get
asked a lot is sort of it's called the
moneymaker effect so what happened and
this is sort of a big catalyst for poker
becoming really popular was I think in
2003 Chris Moneymaker that's actually
his name we make sure it is his last
name he won he spent like a dollar
playing in this like satellite on
PokerStars 1/2 C to the World Series of
Poker Main Event and then went there and
then won the whole thing for like 2 and
1/2 million you know it was a beautiful
cinderella story and then people heard
this and also like they made it seem
like you know it's not like the lottery
where you got to get really really lucky
to become rich
it's literally this guy is really smart
he can read people and it's all skill
and then he did this and it's sort of
like anyone can become a poker star just
like Chris Moneymaker and this cause was
a huge driving force and the popularity
of poker time so a lot so question that
I've wondered myself as you know how
could there actually be so much money
you know because someone has to be
losing this money for you to be winning
this much right so you know what is the
money coming from
you know how can anyone smart and
motivated succeed in poker etc so so ok
so and so what's unique about poker why
is it that Nita why can't you make this
much money playing like chess or
something why can't you play make this
much money playing hockey so what's
unique about poker so I guess four
unique aspects that allow for there to
be so much money so I'm going to talk
about them individually one is I think
everyone is overconfident myself
included two is a gambling self-control
aspects of that three is it's a very
fast evolving game and four is what I
sort of started the class the very first
class I talk about being detected Oh
credit card roulette not being
results-oriented and I think that's very
hard so I'll go through each of each one
of them separately so so yeah one is
this huge overconfidence thing which is
very prevalent so um it's it's normal in
general for people to be overconfident I
don't know how many do you have seen
like the experiment where it's like you
know write down your 95% confidence
intervals for all these states right so
if they're actually 95 percent
confidence intervals and you're
correctly calibrated then actually 19
out of 20 of your intervals should
contain the real thing but like you do
this for a normal person it'll be like
70 percent of the things actually lying
angels
so there's drastically overconfident and
so yeah it's normal to be overconfident
but especially in poker it's I think
poker is among the things I know where
it's easiest you overestimate your own
abilities does I want to suggest any
others is there something else you think
we're like you know everyone thinks
they're good at this thing so I think
it's sort of like two examples that I
think are sort of true okay raise your
hand if you think you're a below median
driver cuz I very rarely talk to someone
who admitted to being bad at driving
everyone I've ever asked about their
driving skill things that are really
good at driving a car myself included I
definitely don't think I'm a below
median driver
another thing is teaching and also I've
also barely talked to someone who thinks
they're worse than me in it teaching I
guess maybe professor no you can see if
you know this but yeah but yeah so so
it's very I think you know because most
things you know someone will admit to
being bad at this but poker it's it's
it's similar to like out of these two
examples I've got the driving teaching
sort of player it's just very easy to
think you're really good at it and and
it's hard to admit to yourself that
you're not good at it yeah someone
saying in poker is you know if you're if
you can't spot the fish that the table
the fish is like the losing player that
everyone is trying to make money from
then like you are the fish this is sort
of a popular saying so so why is
overconfidence so common poker so right
so is this aspect that it's you know
you're it's like a mental battle you're
like mentally battling against your
opponent Izzy what thing is he not and
it's just easy to always assume which I
do in all the like throughout a lot of
this class right in fact to an
exploitative play I'm building a model
for
on it and assuming that they behaved as
a probabilistic machine according to my
model I'm assuming that I'm ahead of my
opponent I'm assuming I'm better there's
also a lot of selective memory I think
it's easy to remember your bad beats the
time they hit a King on the river and be
your aces and it's easy to forget the
times you know you've got really lucky
on the river and beat them so selective
memory I think is a big aspect I think a
lot of clear benchmarks is a big aspect
as well so you know it's not like
running a hundred meters right no one
who takes 30 seconds to run 100 meters
it's got to think oh I can compete in
the Olympics right that's very clear
there's a very clear benchmark how fast
you need to be but in poker you know
even if you don't win tournaments it's
easy to complain it on luck and there's
like different types of tournaments and
it's easy to like bench bend the
benchmarks in a way to convince yourself
that you're better than you are
it needs to hit a lucky streak and
consider it all skill and you can blame
all your losing streaks on luck
so there were some reasons I think I
think poker is a very well designed game
for this purpose into basically tricking
deceiving people into overestimating
their own ability and another aspect of
it is this is and this is what's really
tough about poker I think is even though
it's so easy to be overconfident and
it's such a flaw to be overconfident
it's also in some sense necessary you
know like if you're not confident how
can you take risks right like poker
you're you're gambling and essentially
and you have to do risky things and if
you're not confident how can you do
risky things right and also like you
know if you're trying to like mentally
read your opponent if you're constantly
reminding yourself that you're dumber
than you than you think you are then how
can you actually think that you can out
read your opponent right and like and I
talked about this results-oriented you
need to be confident to trust that you
made a good decision even though your
result was you've lost $10,000 on the
day right so so confidence is also
necessary but it's also so easy to be
overconfident so this this balance of
being exactly the right confidence
thing that I think you know even like
like professional poker players strive
to try to strike the balance between
everyday and I think it's very tough and
it's something I struggle with a lot too
to try to figure out when I'm being
overconfident when I'm being on on your
company so I think one good mentality so
back to this driving thing is I think
it's it's Kevin it's a good mentality
you know if you play poker and you enjoy
it I think it's a great game it's a
beautiful mathematical game and like a
funny day to play with friends you know
if you just are willing to admit you
know I play in this home game every
Friday night I'm probably a below
average player I probably lose on
average 10 bucks every time I play I
think that's totally fine you know it's
just like spending your Friday night
going to see a movie pay 10 bucks and
you're happy to take $10 out of your
wallet and not see it again right you
could I think it's it would be a healthy
mentality for more people to be willing
to do this and just like you know admit
to themselves yeah I enjoy playing poker
and I lose a bit of money but you know I
have fun doing it and you know it's the
same as seeing a movie but in reality I
think this isn't the case you know if
even have these friendly Friday night
games for low states probably if you
asked all the people there do you think
you're meeting your friends everyone's
gonna say yes
everyone's not saying oh I'm going
they're essentially hanging Friday
paying 10 bucks to play poker with my
friends everyone's saying I'm waiting a
bit of money or whatever right so so I
think that's an important holiday to try
to have that I think poker can and I
think it's fine you know if you're if
you're not a you don't have to be the
best at everything right so so one story
I like to tell is so David Einhorn he's
like a billionaire I think he founded
Ramin like capital or something and he
he actually won for million dollars in a
1 million dollar buying poker tournament
and donated it all to charity so and
after the fact you know he's obviously
like a super smart guy and he you know
so he played a 1 million dollar buying
tournament so everyone else playing this
tournament is like a poker professional
with the best in the world and he's just
like this rich billionaire who doesn't
really like he wasn't bad but he he just
started playing for
he was like you know he's a smart guy
and he got coaching to play it but he
was the clear loser in the tournament
and he does admit it if he just said you
know I'm a billionaire I'm happy to
spend a million dollars playing this
tournament I understand I'm probably
expecting to lose like $200,000 or
whatever playing this tournament with
all these guys but I'm fine with it I
have got a million dollars who cares
right and he was very honest and even
after he actually won four million she
didn't come first he came like third he
just admitted you know he said like you
know I was very lucky I came in
expecting to just lose this one million
dollars that I don't care about and then
he just donated all his winnings to
charity anyway but I think like I wish
more people were like him I think that's
a very good mentality you have to just
admit that you're playing poker for fun
and that's totally fine
okay so the second thing I'm going to
talk about is sort of gambling self
control so I think this is this can also
be the downfall of a lot of smart and
motivated people trying to get into
poker so it's so one so yeah so these
are some things that can happen right so
after getting unlucky and the previous
hand you play the next time poorly
because you're like upset you're tilted
as poker players say or playing when
you're tired just to get on the stack
I've definitely done this many times
before in my poker career you know if
I've lost money especially when I feel
like I've gotten unlucky playing against
someone who I'm better than and just
like I've lost money because I got
unlucky
I like won't stop playing until I get
like unstuck which is like winning back
the money unless until I'm in the black
essentially and you know it's terrible
because even if I'm a bit better if I'm
playing with this mentality trying to
get unstuck I'm just going to be making
the low average decisions and it's just
not a good thing to do and also from the
other side you know it can be hard to
rationalize gambling so so it's hard to
stop yourself from gambling too much but
it's also sometimes hard to rationalize
that you know gambling there's a lot of
stigma around gambling
you have to convince yourself that you
know I can I shouldn't be too scared
gambling is I'm playing this game that
involves you or you can call it gambling
I'm playing this game with a lot of luck
and you got to convince yourself that
this is what I'm fine with doing it's
like a lottery and you know you gotta
sometimes to make decisions under
pressure as well and you just go to
rationalize to yourself that you know
yeah this is there's a lot of luck in
this but this is the game I chose to
play so okay the third thing is so fast
evolution I think is another big aspect
of how there was so much money and in
Texas Hold'em for so long so it was a
relatively new game also with a lot of
hidden depth so something like this
could never happen in chess where chess
has been studied for like hundreds of
thousands of years and it's not like a
new game and you know even though the
best player today is still better than
the best player twenty years ago it's
not like the game is evolved a super
fast and whereas Holden was like a new
game at the relatively new game at the
time and just there was so much hidden
depth and it the best players is kept
improving so fast that you know so I
like to say like the best player in the
year 2000 would be like a terrible
player by 2004 and like the best player
in 2004 would be a bad play by 2008 etc
so it's just you know even if you're on
top of the games right now if you stop
studying they're going to be nowhere
near the top of the game in like a year
so it was just so fast can anyone else
think of other examples of things that
were kind of like this CrossFit was when
you get like the winner of the 2009-10
games would wouldn't even compete ohana
okay I don't know that's cause that's
good I didn't know that's great yeah
that's pretty crazy yeah there's one
other thing I can sort of think of uh
how many of you guys have done like math
contests as a kid I think those to my
knowledge I've gotten a lot harder
like just enjoy how good you need to be
you say beyond the United States
national team is way harder now than it
was say 30 years ago from what I've
heard but yeah so this aspect of Texas
Hold'em so this was also a huge driving
factor because you know like it was it
would be easy to tell yourself I was the
best player in the world four years ago
I can obviously sit down at this $1 $2
game and make money right and the answer
would often be no so this was another
reason why a lot of people there was a
lot of money in it because you it's it's
easy to just remember that you were the
best a year ago and just forget that the
this is the times are rising so fast so
that being said so I wanted to also take
this opportunity to suggest some further
readings for I know I've been asked this
yeah so why is that based on your scan
even I think because we are strategies
you have to improve this right yeah yeah
I also think there was a lot of hidden
depth so I mean I think with any new
thing this will be the case but I think
for in poker there were there were many
times where sort of the consensus
amongst the top players was that they
were close to solving the game and then
a year later they would realize they
missed like completely viable strategies
that completely messed up all their
calculations and they have to start over
so I think that was a big like it's it
was it's easy to think that you'd like
solved the game and then suddenly
realized oh I'm nowhere near solving the
game because I forgot about like all of
these different strategies yeah I think
that's it but this might be sort of true
with a lot of I'm trying to think I mean
the biggest thing is it's a new thing
right like it's hard for if this may
happen and like I think in most sports
that have people have done for a long
time people have gradually better right
like you look at like the 100-meter
sprint it's like yeah the world record
is getting broken but it's not like it's
gonna go from 10 seconds to 5 seconds
right they'll go from 10 seconds to nine
point nine nine nine point nine nine
seconds to or something
right so I think just the fact that it's
new is a big aspect but yeah like Texas
Hold'em it would be equivalent you know
to the world record and the hundred
meters being ten seconds that like five
seconds in here later than like two
seconds selectors they're just insane
okay so that being said so some people
have asked me you know if I want to
continue learning about poker reading
poker what what should I do so so that
being said I think the best resources by
far are online a lot of people have
asking about books and I will recommend
some books but I think books basically
go out of date way too fast so I think
in general the best resources are online
so Carter's calm is a website where
basically poker pros can make videos
with themselves while playing and
talking I you do have to pay to get a
subscription okay so this is a bit of a
biased advice just a warning because I'm
I'm a pro card runners but I in amongst
like 58 60 other pros they also donated
some free memberships to students in the
class if you guys looked at the prizes
so you can get some free memberships to
car runners a good free resource is two
plus two forms I think there's a lot of
garbage on those forums nowadays but
still like most of the best poker
players in the world still do use those
forums and post on those forums so two
plus two com there is a lot of you know
just like garbage and banter but if you
are just trying to improve there is good
content on there you just have to find
it and recently so this is a new thing
but on twitch streams so twitches like a
website you can go on to watch
essentially poker pros play in real time
they share their screens and talk
through their hands it's a pretty good
free resource it's sometimes more
entertaining than educational but I
think it's quite good and you know they
would do like a 10-minute delay so that
you can't like watch them and know what
cards they have in case anyone was
considering trying to do that to get an
advantage so these are some online
resources and I will suggest some bucks
although I do think you know most of
these books
I think our reasonably outdated but I do
think they're very in my opinion out of
the books I read these are the best
written books and even if they're a bit
outdated I think like the theory and the
way they're written is very good and
also somewhat entertaining and sort of
gives you an idea on the history of
poker and the evolution of the game so
so my favourite book is the first one it
tells small stakes Hold'em it's by Ed
Miller who's a MIT graduate David's
Polanski and Mason Malmuth so this is
actually Limit Hold'em which is in some
sense a salt game nowadays and no one
place Lemon hold them anymore
so Limit Hold'em is why are you you
can't bet any amount you have to bet as
very specific size but I think this is
one of the classic books and so this is
one of the classic books in poker it's
very well written written by
mathematicians and it just goes through
the basic concepts of poker I think very
very well even though it's for a limit
hold'em and it's a good read yeah so I
might even be a collector's item
nowadays so I one story I like to tell
about this book is so my good friend
Mike McDonald he was uh so he's the guy
who got me into poker and he he would
often tell people he's probably about
this book he says like maybe like 20
times and then he else he's also a guy
who doesn't really like reading so I
think there was a point in his life
where he's read less than 20 different
books and in his life but this specific
book more than 20 times it's a very good
Harrington on Hold'em is on tournaments
it's outdated it's really really badly
outdated but it's something it's very
well written and has some good concepts
that's how I first started learning to
play tournaments it's Harrington I'm
Hold'em one into kill Phil kill everyone
I think is a is pretty good in pretty
up-to-date its decent I think every hand
revealed is Gus Hansen is a very famous
poker player who's been around for
forever it's more so it's it's it's a
book where he goes through every hand he
played in this tournament that he won
and I think it's more entertaining and
educational but definitely a really good
player mathematics have poker by Bill
Chen it's not that practical
don't tell bill dis when he comes Friday
theoretically very interesting if you
like math if you like game theory it's
theoretically very interesting building
a bankroll is a recent book that this
year he didn't have any leftovers to
donate to our class but in the past he's
supported our class and donated a lot of
the book a lot of copies of the book and
I think it's pretty up-to-date and it's
it's for cash game so I think it's very
good okay so the last thing is okay so
back so sort of back to the four things
that will hooker that I think make city
right so the so the fourth one is this
idea of not being results oriented so
yeah so we talked about this a lot in
the first class already this decision
mentality and where you need to care
about the decision you made not the
result you got and I think this actually
is a barrier to a lot of smart and
motivated people like getting into poker
because it it's almost antithetical
right it's your la you know if you're a
smart and motivated person you're used
to like you know you study hard and then
you get like a good result on your test
right no one will ever tell like if you
get a failing grade in your test you're
never gonna be able to let go up to your
parents and be like oh I make good
decisions but I just got really unlucky
I failed the test right like no one's
gonna believe you so it's very um it's
so poker this can happen all the time
right so it is a bit antithetical to to
sort of being motivated um
yeah one thing poker players likes you
laugh at is I don't know if you like to
put like the word results-oriented on
your resume I've seen you know I've seen
like seminars that teach you to become
results oriented and like advertises as
being a great thing you know you achieve
results you you work hard to make
decisions and you achieve results but we
always laugh at this and just because
results oriented is always a negative
term in poker like if in a poker player
says someone is results oriented they
don't respect them very much but I've
seen like resumes out you know where
people say I'm very results or
okay so so yeah so another thing so a
related thing is it's easy to
underestimate the variance in poker and
this is a big aspect to that goes along
with being results-oriented so there's
this like statistical experiment
involving making up sequences of coin
fluffs I've heard of this where where
like a professor would ask students to
make up a sequence of 200 coin flips he
would get half the class to do this and
then here we get the other half to
actually look 200 coins and write down
like heads tails heads heads heads tails
and he could tell with like a hundred
percent seventy which ones are made up
and which ones were real and the way
they did this is basically looking at
which of them what's the longest
sequence of heads in a row or tails in a
row and basically in reality if you flip
200 coins I forget the exact numbers but
I think it's something like you're like
99 percent to get at least like six or
seven of the same thing in a row where
is in all the made-up ones that people
would be like all up it was heads 7
times in a row that can't be random
right so we can't put 7 heads in a row
so I think it's it's known that it's
easy to underestimate how long you can
get unlucky for like it's easy to think
you know I've been unlucky the last
three times that means I must deserve to
get lucky now right but this is like not
true mathematically and it's just very
easy to underestimate variance and
underestimate how likely it is that you
know you're just actually going to lose
10 coin flips in a row in poker it's
gonna happen to you and and and you're
gonna get tilted and it's very important
to control tilt and yeah pretty much
every poker player thinks they're
unluckier than mathematically possible
I've definitely felt like this in many
parts of my career I still feel like
this sometimes now it's very easy to get
this feeling where you just you know how
can it be possible how could I actually
lose 20 point books in a row well it can
happen and one of my folk replied I was
talking to John Cannon he plays a lot of
online poker
this is actually a picture of this desk
he's basically was so angry I think he
like smashed his mouse and made a big
hole in this guy so you know it can
really frustrate you and yeah so encoder
you know and I hate to say this but I
think even if you're working very hard
you do need some lucky big scores along
the way especially at the start to get
into it even if you're a very smart and
working in the right way and this is
also antithetical and smart is sort of
antithetical to start and motivated
people right because we want to believe
that if you work hard and you're smart
then you'll make it for sure but I I
wouldn't say this is true in poker I
think I mean I think I'm willing to
admit I think I was very lucky at the
start you know I had some big scores at
the start that really drove my interest
in the game and really propelled me into
professional poker and I think you know
they're they're probably in a parallel
universe could be another copy of me
that did the exact same things and just
didn't get as lucky as I did at the
start and just never got into poker so
this this fact that you know you do
still need to get lucky even if you make
all the right decisions you make it is
it's sort of a tough thing to sort of a
tough thing to swallow but you know this
is sort of a different story but I I'd
I'd like to argue that that's sort of
true in life too you know the fact that
being started working hard isn't
guarantee success by any means so you
say although that's that's a negative
thing for poker
I like to end you with I like to end
with sort of the what I call the joy of
making good decisions so you know even
though you know not everyone makes it in
poker
but poker players we like to talk about
we like to talk about sort of you're not
really there you shouldn't be trying to
think about making money or whatever
you're sort of just there to enjoy the
game and have an honest opinion on your
ability and calibrate your confidence
I've told the bill gates bill Brunson
sorry but yeah basically you know Bill
Gates I think was a pretty good poker
player for quite a while and he like he
would make money and clearly it was not
his best way to make money like he
probably disability his company and make
like five hundred dollars a second or
something like that but but when asked
about it Bill Gates are just say you
know I love making good decisions I love
thinking about this game making
decisions and even though clearly the
money means nothing to me
it's still important to me as a personal
goal to succeed at this game and make my
even though it doesn't mean anything but
so so it's about this joy of making good
decisions and I think part of the reason
Bill Gates was able to be quite good was
because the money meant nothing to him
he didn't really care about his results
and how much he made her lost clearly he
just focused on making the best
decisions and yeah so it's oh yeah it is
true that there's a decent amount of
luck in poker but I mean yes I would
argue you know life is like and you know
you only look once there's all these
sayings but overall the thing to keep in
mind is like Jennifer Shehadeh talked
about this with the goldilocks video is
so like you want to think of your life
and all your poker career or whatever
has one long session where you're just
trying to make the best decisions and
even if you don't get the best results
today
hope that you get the best better
results throughout the course of your
life so yes okay that's it that's the
end of so that's the end of what I
wanted to say about the general poker
and what I hope you take away from this
class from a non mathematical non poker
point of view I guess there's a bit of
time for questions there's a lot of
things I didn't talk about but I'm happy
to answer questions about it so yeah I'm
happy to answer any questions now yeah
now that there are no longer any class
tournaments where can I go to play to
get better and improve okay so I think
so you can't obvious there's an MIT
poker club and they run tournaments on
PokerStars similar to the way the class
works the way you can get into the poker
club is solely Maria's part of it um she
is she's like one of the exact you may
be asked her ship sent her an email I
can ask her so I can ask I'll ask her
and I'll send some
the class if you guys are interested in
continuing playing poker on PokerStars
and yeah so there's the MIT poker club
and I know in the past sometimes the
class I the class has continued playing
students after the class is over we
would have like a tournament every
Saturday or something for people replies
by it I don't know they didn't last very
long I think people quickly lost
interest in it but yeah I think just the
poker club actually um mark you're
you're on the poker club right so you
maybe you can say something answer that
question so maybe okay I'll find some
information from Lee Murray and Martin
and I'll send something to the class and
I'll give you guys some pointers yeah
yeah so I guess I've yeah so I mean
definitely I I've gone through Baghdad
swings and times where I really hated
the game I think that I mostly just took
a break so yeah I mostly just took a
break so the first time I had yes of my
first couple of downswings when I was
first starting yeah I kind of just took
a break from the game for a while like a
month or something and then came back
that's sort of what I did
nowadays I'd say I'd say in like the
last four years I've been I'd like to
think I was fairly good at feeling of
down swings you know I've sort of went
through enough down swings where I kind
of was able to just keep it together for
the most part like maybe I play slightly
less but I wouldn't quit off together
yeah so for like small cash games online
what kind of edge do you think you have
firstly and then like what kind of edge
what would you like you're like
borderline edge where like it suddenly
wouldn't come with it anymore
Oh think that okay so how much edge I
think I have so is so in other than cash
games I think it's the thing is I don't
really specialize in cash games so I
never really played them so I'd say it's
probably very little I mean I'm sure I
can find like a low enough stakes where
I'll have a significant edge or even
enjoyment so yeah yeah so in tournaments
I mean yeah like I'd say yeah I'd say it
there's still yeah like I still a decent
decent edge and I'll play it before but
mostly I'd say I'll play poker mostly
for fun nowadays I don't I don't
I rarely force myself to do it for
making money I'd say most of the time
I'm playing you know I'm still trying to
make good decisions cuz I enjoy doing
that but I'm not really doing it for the
hourly rate yeah yeah so what about so
maybe the best game played in the world
how much would they make twenty-five
fifty cents all right twenty-five fifty
cents online uh uh so I don't have a
great sense of this but like it let me
think um I think this okay so the thing
is the sort of the players who are sort
of considered the top players in the
world who play like very high say psyche
nosebleed stakes with like 100 $200 big
blinds or something
it sort of the variance is so high that
it's it's not really accepted who's the
best because if it was accepted you know
someone had a someone had a win rate
over someone else than the guy who was
worse just wouldn't be play so the only
reason those games run is because they
all think they have a winner so I it's
hard for me to say the number because
I'm not going to know better than them
what their true when rates are against
each other and they're all gonna tell me
something different cuz they all think
they're beating the other guys as far as
how much like a really top player can
win at like a low stakes game I it's
still it's something to be very
significant like I think making
something like maybe like five or six
big blinds per hundred so that would be
yeah five or six big money four hundred
I think is maybe doable at a reasonably
low stakes if you're like one of the
very best so that would so by that I
mean every hundred hands you mate it's
quite a lot it's quite generous but the
let's say let me let's
every hundred hands you make five big
blinds so so let's say you play twenty
five seven fifty Cent so if there is so
25 757 five big blinds is 250 make that
every hundred hands if you play like six
tables you can get in about a hundred
fit and spur our I'm twenty hands per
hour sets six hundred hands per hour so
six so it was six hundred hands per hour
so it's six times 250 so it's like 15
bucks but I mean so it's not a lot but I
mean those guys can play stage way
higher than 25 second 50 cent and still
have a slightly smaller edge but right
so it's so if you imagine they play like
they might shoot $2 to $55 then suddenly
you multiply them out they make by 10 I
mean you would decrease it it because
there they probably wouldn't make five
big blinds per hour over five Big Mike's
per hundred but um but I think those
numbers are ballpark correct yeah yeah
looks like a good strategy for what's a
good strategy for playing at a casino
and exploiting people I think okay so I
think one thing that's okay why general
thing that's good to do is you go there
you sleep at night and you go there at
like 7:00 a.m. and play against people
who I've been tilted and angry for
and you just woke up at 7 a.m. in the
morning and you're and you're in such a
good mood and they're on a bad mood and
you can learn a lot of money and in
terms of like specific a specific
strategy I think it depends a lot on the
player I think in general playing tight
is pretty good at least I say I consider
myself in general and tight player and I
think a lot of money and decent amount
of money can be made at casinos against
recreational players just by them
getting bored you know they got a nine
minute table you're only paying the
blinds
one and a half blinds 79 hands you can
easily get away with them late playing
like you know pocket nines plus ace
queen plus I mean that's extreme but
like you know they'll probably still
call you because they're bored like
they're not going to think like you know
this guy's I'm gonna just fold right so
like one disadvantage of that strategy
is there is always going to pull to you
but in practice I don't think that's
like what happens so I think in general
the plain tight is not a is it will
always be a pretty good strategy I
casinos against recreational players not
really because I think it's how could
you me things but yeah I think yeah I
mean it really is hard to judge like
really though you the thing is you basic
especially in tournaments in cash games
it's slightly easier to judge because
the sort of you can just look at your
data points into the like converge
faster in tournaments the variance is so
high you can't really use your
tournament results I think the most
important thing for me personally was
just talking to players and I'm having
very honest friends who would tell me if
they thought I was worse than someone
else and tell me not to play them and I
think that's probably thing that
benefited me the most just you know
being able to talk to players better
than me or like this at a similar level
to me and just getting their opinion
from them talking to Mia you know if
they think I'm not good enough I want
and I think that's sort of them one of
the most important things is just
getting good feedback from your friends
inside asleep ya know since we can't
really play online here we can do we can
do that as you know either like every
weekend so we can play more money but
some good motivation to keep some in the
game
okay mentality and the skills will then
continue I don't add a like or no jobs
okay so let's say okay say no I'll
adjust a few things yeah so one thing
that I didn't really formally announce
but yeah so one thing you pointed out is
play online poker for money is illegal
in Massachusetts it's it's I mean it's
not it's it's illegal not from like a
police can't come arrest you but it's
over but the website will take all your
money if they find out you're playing
for Massachusetts but I don't believe
it's like it's written Massachusetts law
or something I don't believe though you
might almost a police kind of rusty but
but yeah so the question was you know if
we can't play online what can we do so I
think it is legal in New Jersey and
Nevada so you can move to New Jersey so
okay so in terms of and you don't okay
yeah so if you don't want to go to the
casino every weekend so what I was going
to do so okay so what's the motivation
to keep playing so I think I'm tried in
this class to sort of give examples of
where I think poker is very useful just
in terms of like it related help ogres
related to non poker stuff you know like
calibrating your confidence figuring out
what your biases are and stuff like that
so and also think you know it's a fun
game it's it's a very fun game it's
mathematically interesting but yeah I
mean you know if you don't enjoy playing
the game much and since you can't really
make money playing it in Massachusetts
yeah then if both of those are true then
there's not that reason to play it if
you don't enjoy it I think that's just
the biggest thing if you enjoy it and
you enjoy the decision-making I think
it's it's very fun and it's also very
good for you
all right cool yeah so if there's no
more questions then I guess yeah so
we'll call it here and then this Friday
will be the last class there's two more
names of tournaments left and yeah I'm
excited for Friday for Bill's lecture
and do hand out the prizes